after initially laughing at Chris Rock's
joke what led Will Smith to get up walk
on stage and slap the comedian at the
Oscars ceremony is there bad blood in
their past keep watching for the details
there have been plenty of memorable and
even shocking Academy Awards moments
over the years but at the 2022 Oscars
one was so unexpected that it's next to
impossible for anyone watching to forget
a little over halfway through the Show
comedian Chris Rock took to the stage to
present the award for best documentary
as rock made what he believed were
standard issue jokes about some of the
celebs in the audience he turned his
attention to Will Smith and Jada Pinkett
Smith both of whom were seated near the
stage rock made a joke about Pinkett
Smith's shaved head saying he couldn't
wait to see her in GI Jane 2. a
reference to the 1997 movie starring
Demi Moore will then took to the stage
and slapped Rock in the face before
taking his seat and yelling at the
presenter
keep my wife's name out of your mouth I
think
I think
the fling turn of events derailed the
entire Oscar's show and the Knight never
really recovered from it viewers
immediately reacted on Twitter appearing
to neither condone Smith's actions nor
deem Rock's joke acceptable shortly
after Will Smith won the best actor
award for his titular role in King
Richard he took the stage clearly
emotional about what just happened
though he apologized to the academy it
is very likely that there was a deeper
reason for Smith so publicly and
suddenly defending his wife on live
television as of the making of this
video neither Smith nor Pinker Smith
have issued an official statement about
what occurred at the 2022 Oscars aside
from Will's acceptance speech they've
also offered no explanation for Will's
reaction to Rock's joke but it clearly
cut deeper than the comedian intended
shortly after a variety executive editor
remains a Tuda confirmed on Twitter that
Smith hitting rock and yelling at him
was not a planned or scripted bit tweets
rolled in reminding everyone that
Pinkett Smith has alopecia she first
went in public with Her diagnosis on her
Facebook live show red table talk in
2018 she said I was in the shower one
day and then just handfuls of hair just
in my hands and I was just like oh my
God am I going bald in December 2021 she
opened up about her hair loss on
Instagram telling her followers
just all of a sudden one day
look at this line right here nubbing
that Pinkett Smith is living with an
autoimmune disease makes it slightly
more understandable why her husbands did
not take kindly to rock mocking her hair
last so publicly particularly since it's
a condition with which she has clearly
struggled as seen in the live telecast
though will initially laughed at the
joke Jada was visibly unamused it's also
entirely possible that Will Smith's
anger at Chris Rock predates the 2022
Academy Awards because this isn't the
first time Ruckus publicly joked about
Pinkett Smith on stage at the Oscars in
2016 pinky Smith refused to attend the
ceremony boycotting the event due to the
awards once again having an all-white
slate of acting nominees The Smiths
weren't the only notable Hollywood
talent to ditch the ceremony either
other celebrities to skip the event
according to the independent included
Ava Duvernay Spike Lee and Ryan coogler
yet when Chris Rock took to the Oscar
stage as that Year's host it was Pinkett
Smith he chose as his Target he implied
she wasn't invited at all saying saying
Jada said she's not coming I was like
isn't she on a TV show at the time
Pinker Smith publicly dismissed Rock's
commentary but she and her husband's
private feelings about the matter may
have been different from what she said
publicly whether it was a long-standing
bad blood or a knee-jerk reaction to a
joke Will Smith's actions certainly took
the Academy Awards to a strange place
that will not be forgotten for a long
while check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more Looper videos
about your favorite celebrities are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]